hello and welcome to this video aladino
with the opponent and yes we got an open
the soil cloudy the sound so okay so
ever ever three yeah this is not really
great careful first I guess guess three
against accelerated is normally deemed a
bit dubious 26s correct not entirely
sure about the details you should be
three and then this 94 94 on IG form
both moves are possible
[Music]
94 ever was is there something
complicated there that I try to remember
95 him then then I check on a five-night
f5 I think I can take on c3 ok I think
95 is actually somewhat complicated yeah
but i'm not sure Knight g4 is also
interesting if i remember correctly like
takes Bishop before so I never looked at
this in any detail when I've studied
this years ago and it is it is a bad
line for a while and I don't quite
remember the details so we'd we add that
the player with a somewhat good blitz
writing would stumble into that because
it is like accelerated dragon 101 right
okay let's see may 95 is the only move
that makes any sort of sense so a check
check and now I have to move the night
back yeah this knight c6 and then take
only 70 this isn't isn't all that bad um
okay
that isn't bad it says something
something else I can do here let's see
five don't know if that really does much
yeah this isn't so terrible
check I mean this is definitely not a
problem for black but it doesn't look
like a representation of the whole
opening and it is really bad mainly
Knight g4 is better I don't know let's
continue and don't think about this too
much rook e8 or the immediate immediate
95 also looks good I mean I'm very
comfortable here absolutely that you
kind of expect more after f3 is played
ok so here we have chicken
yeah here is nothing really great let's
just do this I didn't have to play this
move probably anyway okay check it's
really nothing at all absolutely nothing
[Music]
he's got the bishop pal and I don't
think it gives him an advantage share
with all the pawns being completely
symmetrical but it's a pretty bad
opening result against this line maybe
maybe natural force better I don't know
really it's have been a long time let's
see what he does
angling for 95 I don't know 93 maybe
nothing going on okay so he allows me to
take this ok so the ship g6 does he
really want to do that or what's the
point here there is no point really just
is a pawn down and still not easy to to
do something with this
c3 is also under fire that might be a
draw in this one no 95 is not the draw
what am i doing in time warning how do i
get to that porn it's the problem how do
I get down maybe I should just push push
my pawns check check I wanted to check
1g5 this is almost made just almost
Shatner this is of course yes correct
epic check life forfeit on time ah shaky
game
come on yeah I have to check the opening
this this is really not good for wide
okay the end I didn't know that sure I
mean I looked at this like 20 years ago
maybe it wasn't all that terrible for
white but usually this is this is not
deemed to be any good this this i
remember was also interesting what this
is also not all that clear isn't here
yeah you know it really has a bad
reputation I hope you still believe me
you bet this seems to be okay I remember
something like that but not precisely
let's see five seems to be better okay I
mean of course this is nothing great for
what anyway that it's not not terrible
one castle to create and like it's
comfortable but it's not not a great
advantage or anything we can't the way
it went it was kind of similar just with
the knight on f6 I think okay this is
just extremely unequal issue the bishop
I isn't isn't that important here if
anybody of course white has a symbolic
advantage but I don't think it's much
should be three young lady yeah I don't
know he just gave me that poem
[Music]
they are king be 3m King 23 don't ask me
what I was thinking I was thinking this
would be some kind of fork with just not
the case I was extremely lucky down King
III would have just one you this isn't
so easy yeah two ponds I'm two pawns up
but the computer self has this is
roughly equal I cannot get anything
going them against the heat upon it was
probably helpful okay now that was a big
one at 66 seconds after this it's a draw
according to the engine I have to be
even a bit careful if it gets b7 you
will get a six and then I might lose
this okay thanks for watching